il devient le 26e Premier ministre de
l'histoire de la 5e République il est
aussi le plus jeune à 34 ans Gabriel
hatal succède à ellisabeth borne à
Matignon il a fallu attendre quelques
heures pourir passer la nuit la matinée
aussi mais dans quelques minutes
l'actuel ministre de l'éducation
nationale sera officiellement le nouveau
chef du gouvernement ça vient de tomber
pas de communiqué encore Carl mus
bonjour bonjour bonjourb rédacteur en
chef du Figaro Magazine bon pour
l'instant c'est pas encore très
clairement officialisé mais ça y est
c'est fait oui c'est que depuis hier on
avait l'impression que ça pouvait être
Gabriel Atal C impression c'est c'est
transformé en certitude aujourd'hui
c'est voilà
on% au cours de la soirée on a pu douter
parce que il y a eu des des bruits comme
quoi le le choix de Gabriel etal ne
plaisait pas à tout le monde au sein de
la h j'ai hâte que vous me racontiez
tout ça et en fait c'est toujours la
même chose c'estàdire qu'à partir du
moment où vous êtes transgressif puisque
le choix de gabrielal est quand même une
nomination transgressive nommer
quelqu'un de de 34 ans euh ben vous
bousculer des gens alors vous bousculez
qui vous bousculez ceux qui commençaient
déjà à se préparer pour 2027 pour
l'élection présidentielle et qui se
disait je suis le seul sur ce créneau je
peux y arriver euh tant qui a Elisabeth
borne bien sûr je risque rien et après
il m un aut elle il ne peut pas aller
plus haut voà voilà et là qu'est-ce que
fait Emmanuel Macron au-delà de tout ce
qu'il veut faire pour le gouvernement
tout ça c'est qu'il met dans la course à
l'Élysée un nouveau euh champion euh qui
est jeune et qui est complètement sur
son axe
euh politique puisque Gabriel Atal est
un des des rares parmi ceux qui peuvent
prétendre à 2027 à dire mais moi je
considère que le l'axe central est
toujours la bonne stratégie il y en
avait qu'un jusqu'ici qui disait ça
c'est François Baayou donc voilà
pourquoi François Baayou par exemple
était pas très chaud à l'idée que
Gabriel Atal soit nommé à Matignon parce
que benah voilà ça il est plus tout seul
sur ce crénon tout ça c'est de la
politique politicienne he Carl mus parce
qu'on va parler du fond on va bien être
obligé de se demander ce qui est
l'atalisme peut-être on va commencer à
en parler ce que va pouvoir faire le
nouveau Premier ministre mais tiens
Gabriel Atal est-ce que c'est le premier
effet waouh
depuis l'élection de Emmanuel Macron en
2017 parce que bon la nomination
d'Édouard Philippe çaait pas
enthousiasmer grand monde et tout le
monde s'en moqué on attendait plutôt ce
qu'allait faire Emmanuel Macron Jean
Castex on peut pas dire que ça avait
soulevé les fou Elisabeth borne non plus
après une élection assez terne en 2022
depuis 7 ans la vie politique n'avait
pas été aussi revigouré avec une attente
peut-être des Français sur une
personnalité vous avez raison si je
reviens sur 2017 l'effet waou il est
arrivé après le covid c'està-dire que là
édard Philippe s'est révélé c'est les
Français l'ont l'ont écouté l'ont
regardé l'ont apprécié c'est presque
moment où il est parti qu'il a commencé
à être aimé hein c'est parce qu'il est
devenu populaire et parce qu'il avait un
agenda qui était différent désormais de
celui du président que le président l'a
viré et que les Français se sont dit bah
puisque nous on n'aime pas Emmanuel
Macron finalement lui il est peut-être
bien mais donc il y a eu cet effet
retard après vous avez raison Jean
Castex les Français ne le connaissait
pas il était là pour une mission il l'a
réalité Elisabeth borne les Français ne
la connaissaient pas non plus et en plus
elle a dû euh être vraiment dans le dur
avec cette réforme des retraites et plus
le projet de loi immigration bien là on
a effectivement un effet waou parce que
alors que vous voyez pardon car vouscoup
parce que les gens se demandent
peut-être on est on a les images devant
l'hôtel de matinon visiblement les les
camion de des traiteurs sont en train
d'arriver a toujours une petite
réception lorsqu'on change de Premier
ministre je vous coupe mais voilà soyez
pas pouvoir voilà dans quelques minutes
normalement euh pour pour plusieurs
éléments d'abord parce que c'est
quelqu'un Gabriel at qui est un
politique euh pur ancien du du Parti
socialiste qu' a été conseiller euh de
Marie soltouren de 2012 à 2017 quand été
ministre de la santé des affaires
sociales et c'est quelqu'un qui est un
très bon communicant oui je me suis
amusé à regarder le nombre de portraits
qui avait été fait sur lui depuis qu'il
est ministre donc depuis 2018 et ben il
a coché à peu près toutes les cases il y
a
h ah oui c'est vrai vous avez fait le
portrait de lui dans le figar magazine
je n'y ai pas coupé je l'ai fait mais
d'ailleurs c'est moiil avait proposé on
l'avait titré en 2020 avril 2023 le
joker de Matignon voyez de d'Emmanuel
Macron pour pour matigon bah oui parce
que on avait tous décelé cette ambition
et les les qualités qu'il avait et qui
correspondait à ce queou très
honnêtement avril 2023 est-ce que vous
vous pensiez vraiment que Gabriel Atal
pouvait devenir Premier ministre il a 34
ans il entrait à à l'éducation nationale
et on se disait tiens c'est n était pas
encore derrière ce moment on dit tiens
il y a peut-être un espoir dans ce
garçon mais là de le voir devenir
Premier ministre est-ce que la semaine
dernière vous pensez encore que Gabriel
Atal pouvait le devenir on savait qu'il
avait cette ambition oui on savait parce
que des gens le voyaient voyaient son
comportement voyaient son ascension vous
savez c'est pas un hasard si vous êtes
élu député en 2017 en 2018 vous devenez
secrétaire d'État euh sous euh
Jean-Michel Blanquer à l'éducation
chargée du SNU oui bon vous marchez vous
vous faites bien au point que euh quand
Jean Castex est'est nommé à Matignon
vous devenez porte-parole du
gouvernementparole c'est un poste
essentiel extraordinaire il a il a été
plutôt très bon tout le monde s'est
accordé à le dire et on se souvient Carl
de Jean Castex qui sort de l'Élysée
après un conseil des ministres il vient
d'être nommé et il cherche à constituer
son gouvernement euh Gabriel al est
porte-parole mais il n'est que
porte-parole et parfois on est
porte-parole et on a un autre ministère
et cette petite phrase attend un nos un
nos àronger pour je il faut trouver un
os arranger pour le jeu natal qui ne
l'aura pas parce que Emmanuel Macron
veut quelqu'un qui qui soit à plein
temps et et d'ailleurs
euh c'est ce qu'il me confiait il y a un
an quand quand je l'avais suivi et il me
disait ça ça lui a permis de d'avoir une
vision transversale de tout ce qui se
passait parce que Jean Castex a joué le
jeu l'associé à toutes les réunions
interministérielles et alors c'est un
c'est un énorme bosseur infatigable il
peut passer plusieurs nuits blanches à
travailler il récupérera après le
weekend mais il il avale voilà les les
dossiers techniques il réussit bien dans
son rôle de porte-parole ce qui lui
permet quand Elisabeth borne est nommée
Premier ministre première ministre de
demander les comptes publics là encore
un poste transversal essentiel pour le
rouage de l'administration Nicolas sarzi
par exemple c'est le le poste que
veulent les ambitieux parce qu'ils se
savent que c'est le un des postes
essentiels il y a l'intérieur le budget
ou vous tenez les manettes de l'État
vous êtes au commande c'est-àdire que un
ministère ne peut rien faire sans le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale par
exemple ne peut rien faire sans que le
budget lui dise ok tu as cette somme
d'argent voilà c'est des
négociations voilà c'est des arbitrage
et et vous connaissez c'est pour ça
quand on dit il a plus vous frottez à
l'Assemblée parce qu'il faut ch année
faire voter le budget donc vous êtes
aussi dans l'hémicycle oui ex et vous
avez entièrement raison d'évoquer ce
cette situation de l'Assemblée parce que
ça c'est un des moments clé où Emmanuel
Macron qui l'a déjà repéré se dit ah
mais il est très bon vous vous souvenez
de débat sur les retraites printemps
2023 vous avez trois ministres bon il y
a le ministre chargé des Relations avec
le Parlement Franck rester vous avez
Olivier du celui qui ministre du Travail
ministre du Travail qui mène la réforme
et qui qui est un peu englué parce qu'
il est dans dans les affaires techniques
il est dans la négociation il a il a il
a du mal voilà il y arri et puis il y a
Gabriel Atal en tant que ministre des
comptes publques qui est là et qui porte
politiquement finalement le texte qui
répond politiquement à la France
insoumise qui qui leur répond qui qui
les fait sortir du bois qui arrive et à
tel point ça marche tellement bien que
quand il faut envoyer un ministre sur un
20inur Emmanuel Macron dit vous envoyez
Gabriel al ouais ah c'est lui VO et ben
oui parce que il a repéré que il est bon
en communication il est bon en politique
et donc il a ce cocktail là qui plaît à
Emmanuel Macron et donc quand vous avez
tout ce parcours là vous vous pouvez pas
dire bah à 34 ans il est trop jeune non
vous savez quoi il connaît mieux le le
fonctionnement du gouvernement qu'un
Jean-Marc hraud qui est nommé à Matignon
par François Hollande alors qu'il n'a
jamais été ministre c'est pas lui faire
un jure c'est juste voilà un constat je
lis plusieurs réaction XxXXx sur
lefigero.fr qui nous fait qui nous dit
bonne nomination place aux jeunes
d'autres qui sont un peu un peu
sceptique notamment sur sur Youtube
Peter Circe qui nous dit Atal les grillé
pour 2027 alors ça ça m'intéresse vous
avez commencé à me parler de politique
politicienne des ambitions de chacun
j'en perds mon stylo avec on les
connaî Bruno Le Maire Gérald haranin
Édouard Philippe qui ont tous pour
ambition de devenir président dans dans
3 ans et on dit depuis plusieurs
décennies que ce poste de Premier
ministre il vous grille et ça a été vrai
il vous grille on pense à baladure on
pense à Chirac on pense à Jospin on
pense à Manuel Vals plus récemment
pourquoi tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que finalement pour Gabriel Atal c'est
un trempelin alors
euh c'est la roche tarpayenne est à côté
du Capitol hein donc voilà euh il faut
faire attention parce que matigon est un
trempelin au sens où vous êtes premier
ministre donc vous allez être sous le
feu des projecteurs les Français vont
vous identifier vous aimez ou ne pas
vous aimer mais voilà vous entrez si
vous me permettez l'expression dans dans
la cour des grands oui il y a une
tradition qui veut que quand vous
commencez à monter les marches de de
Matignon vous regardez ce qui se passe
de l'autre côté de la
scène à l'Élysée et vous rêvez d'y aller
pourquoiou il y a pas plus haut he de
toute façon des anciens premier
ministres me l'ont très bien expliqué
c'est quand vous êtes à matigon vous
avez la main sur l'ADEM administration
c'est vous qui vous tapez le sale boulot
vous faites tout et vous voyez à
l'Élysée le président de la République
alors certes il a été élu par les
Français lui il vous donne des ordres il
donne des impulsions mais il se met pas
les mains dans le camp Louis et il y a
un moment c'est humain le Premier
ministre se dit mais en fait tout ce que
je fais là euh bah je suis très bien
capable de le faire à l'Élysée euh parce
que si j'y arrive là euh voilà je
pourquoi j'y arriv pas ils oublient
juste une chose c'est qu'à Matignon vous
êtes nommé à l'Élysée vous êtes élu et
oui et oui mais c'est il y a une marche
ça s'appelle les Français l'élection
présidentielle et c'est pas parce que le
Président de la République vous a choisi
pour aller à Matignon pour plein de
critères qui sont très différents à
chaque fois que vous êtes oui c'est pas
parce que vous êtes le d'une certaine
manière le meilleur finit par arriver à
l'Élysée parce que les Français l'ont
choisi et il y a qu'il y a combien plus
de 35 millions de personnes qui votent
pour vous alors que il faut toujours
retenir cette leçon de Nicolas Sarkozy
en politique ce n'est pas forcément le
meilleur qui gagne c'est celui qui reste
accroché à la part quand tous les autres
dvis ouais parce que Nicolas SAR il a
cette expérience pourquoi il dit ça
parce que lui il rêvait d'aller à
matigon de s'imposer face à Jacques
Chirac on lui met Jean-Pierre rafarin
puis ensuite on lui met Dominique de
Villepin puis à chaque fois on lui dit
non non mais oui d'accord mais il y a un
meilleur il y a Jupé qui est meilleur
Villepin il est meilleur ouais sauf que
lui il a été élu à l'Élysée et que non
n'ont jamais réussi à franchir cette
étape là ce qui veut dire quoi c'est
qu'effectivement Matignon peut être un
trempelin mais peut aussi vous desservir
parce que est-ce que que vous êtes en
train de me dire que Gabriel hatal
contrairement à tous les autres n'avait
pas encore de par son âge la stature
politique le poids politique qu' daranin
le maire Édouard Philippe et que lui ça
lui donne cette stature alors que les
autres auraient eu plus de chance de
perdre des points alors que Gabriel Atal
a plus de chance d'en gagner il va en
gagner forcément parce qu'il va comme
vous dites il va se lester de de cette
stature il va avoir cette armure ce ce
passage à les Jeux Olympiques en plus
voà mais ça veut pas dire qu'il va
réussir le le passage directement de
Matignon à l'Élysée mais euh
doard Philippe il est passé à Matignon
et c'est ce passage à Matignon qui lui
permet aujourd'hui de prétendre être le
candidat à l'Élysée et de que les
Français le voient comme candidat et
d'ailleurs dans les sondages disent ça
ferait il ferait un bon candidat ils
peuvent éventuellement voter pour lui ce
qui ce qui ce qui est difficile ce qu'on
ce qu'on évoque c'est le passage
directement de matigon à l'Élysée et là
c'est vrai souvent d'ailleurs ça a été
le cas pour la cohabitation vous les
exemples que vous citiez Chirac baladure
Jospin ils étaient en cohabitation ils
ont fait le sale boulot et et c'était
compliqué de de devenenir président à ce
moment-là parce que les Français avaient
pas gardé une bonne image donc Gabriel
Atal si on si on suit un un un plan de
carrière j'aime pas ce mot-là pour les
politiques mais mais un cheminement il
va y avoir ce passage à Matignon il est
jeune encore pour prétendre être
candidat à l'Élysée voilà il a il a 2 3
ans pour pour réussir ce passage ça
n'avait pas arrêté Emmanuel Macron à peu
près au même
âge oui sans sans être passé par matinon
absolument exactement ni même parem ni
même sans passer devant les Français
vous évoquez quelque chose qui est très
intéressant c'est que Emmanuel Macron a
rompu avec ce qu'il avait fait avant qui
était de nommer à Matignon des gens que
les Français ne connaissaient pas oui
tiens ça ça m'intéresse pour la première
fois il nomme un poids lourd c'est pas
Géral Bruno le non c'est un peu lourd
c'est un des quatre ministres on
appelait les quatre mousquetaires cétait
les ministres les plus populaires du
gouvernement tout simplement est-ce
qu'il prend un risque est-ce que il
n'avait pas le choix et est-ce que
finalement Emmanuel Macron est entré
dans une autre ère il arrive à la fin de
son histoire à la tête de l'État bon il
lu reste 3 ans mais on est plus proche
de la fin que du début et maintenant il
lui faut des héritiers il devient le
vieux sage Emmanuel Macron qui peut
faire un roi défaire un autre il prend
un risque il prend un risque pour lui
c'est-à-dire que vous trouvez mais oui
parce que il va falloir qu'il prenne sur
lui qu'il se change lui-même ah qu'il
accepte de ne plus être omnipotent bah
alors pas forcément omnipotent ça il
pourra l'ARE parce que Gabriel Atal
appliquera ce que lui dira de faire le
le président de la République mais il va
falloir qu'il accepte qu'un premier
ministre soit plus populaire que lui que
c'est ce qui risque d'arriver c'est que
la nomination de Gabriel tal il va y
avoir ce que vous appeliez lesffet waou
les Français vont peut-être l'apprécier
en tout cas il est était le le
deuxè dans le baromètre verriant Figaro
Magazine il y avait édard Philippe en1
et lui arrivait à être le le premier des
ministres en popularité avec Bruno lumer
mais donc s'il est sur cette lancée là
il peut être en tout cas plus populaire
qu'Emmanuel Macron il va falloir
qu'Emmanuel Macron l'accepte ce qui est
pas facile quand hidor Philippe a été
plus populaire que lui c'est le moment
où il l'a renvoyé aujourd'hui étant
donné qu'il n'a plus rien à jouer en 27
d'une part et d'autre part c'est son
choix il le sait il ne nomme pas
quelqu'un inconnu des Français ça aurait
pu être le cas s'il avait choisi
Sébastien le corornu ou Julien de
Normandie qui étaient les deux autres
noms qui étaient cités et puis il nomme
un poids lourd sauf qu'il nomme un poids
lourd qui lui doit tout c'est pas le cas
de Bruno Lemire et de Jal Darmanin même
si ils se sont fait aussi dans le siège
d'Emmanuel Macron Édouard Philipp lui
doit tout mais il est plus âgé donc
c'est très différent là c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui lui doit sa carrière
politique voilà VO c'est il est député
en 2017 dans le sillage d'Emmanuel
Macron il est nommé ministre puis
porte-parole parce qu'Emmanuel Macron
donne son aval donc il sait ce qu'il
doit Emmanuel
Macron je ne pense pas qu'il fera en
tout cas pas tout de suite ce qu'a fait
Laurent fabus avec François mitteran lui
c'est lui moi c'est moi pour essayer de
se détacher ça arrivera peut-être à un
moment il va devoir mais aujourdi
présidentielle aujourd'hui il va coller
à à Emmanuel Macron appliquer la
politique d'emmanu ça c'est évident donc
de ce point de vue là Emmanuel Macron
prend moins de risque que s'il avait
nommé Bruno Le Maire ou Gérald daranin
dont on aurait pu penser parce que
c'était pas des historiques c'est plutôt
des rallés des gens qui auraient
peut-être pu claquer la porte à un
moment en disant à la manière d'un
Jacques Chirac en 76 je n'ai pas les
moyen d'appliquer la politique je quitte
le gouvernement et se prépare pour
l'élection présidentielle nous avons
reçu un communiqué Carl difficile de
faire plus court difficile le faire plus
clair communiqué de la Présidence de la
République ça c'est en gros hein en haut
le président de la République à nommé
monsieur Gabriel Atal Premier ministre
et a chargé de former un gouvernement
voilà c'est très clair et ça y est c'est
officiel j'ai un commentaire sur Youtube
euh je crois que je vais le retrouver
jocos un jeune pour 2027 comme
bardela ça c'est l'une des grandes des
grand l'un des grands sujets depuis hier
Emmanuel Macron a nommé Gabriel Atal
pour contrer Jordan Bardella peut-être
dans les années qui viennent mais dans
les semaines qui viennent dans les mois
qui vien é eurées non non c'est une très
bonne remarque parce que depuis quelques
temps l'Élysée est obnubilé par Jordan
Bardella en fait au moment des
rencontres de Saint-Denis organisé à la
rentrée de l'année dernière l'Élysée
nous avait fait savoir à nous journalist
politique qui a été impressionné par
Jordane Bardella alors on voit bien
l'aspect tactique c'était un moyen aussi
de de de montrer que les autres travaill
ne travaillaient pas et essayer de le
détacher de de de Marine Le Pen mais il
y avait malgré tout une réalité qui
était voilà vous avez un jeune homme de
27 28 ans qui travaille qui qui qui est
très bossseur et qui plaît au français
Jordan Bardella est aussi en tête dans
dans les 50 personnalités préféré des
Français avec sondage ifob JDD première
fois qu'un politique rentre dans les 50
premiers et c'est Jordan B maintenant et
donc effectivement dans les arguments
favorables à la nomination de gabrielal
il y a cet aspect de je moi aussi j'ai
mon jeune de 34 ans de la même
génération que je prop particulier dit
comme ça j'ai mon
jeune je vois l'idée vous me permettez
des expressions comme ça j'aime beaucoup
et effectivement la première étape
de Gabriel Atal ça va être de gagner les
élections européennes il sera pas tête
de liste évidemment c'est pas lui mais
c'est amatigon il va être chargé
d'inverser la vapeur parce qu'on voit
bien sur les derniers sondages que que
le rassemblement national de avec la
liste menée par Jordan mellaa prenait de
plus en plus de points au point de
dépasser les 30 % alors que la liste de
renaissance commençait à à tangenter les
15 % était passé de 20 à 18 donc on
voyait bien là que les courbes
commençaient à à à s'écarter et qu'il y
avait un danger et donc le risque pour
Gabriel Atal aussi c'est de se cramer
dès le mois de juin avec les élections
européennes mais il va devoir mener ce
combat là face à Jordan B et ce qui est
amusant c'est que les deux hommes se
connaissent bien non pas qu'ils se côtoi
souvent mais que pendant la les
campagnes souvent ils étaient appelés
sur les plateaux télé à débattre l'un
face à l'autre et donc ils se
connaissent bien et euh même pour le
coup pour avoir fait les portraits de
des deux de les avoir suivis et et qui
ils m'ont parlé tous les deux c'est la
même génération c'est la génération
j'allais dire Netflix c'està-dire sur
leurs écrans ils regardent des séries
euh Gabriel àal quand il a besoin de
décompresser le soir après une journée
de boulot même sil est 2h du matin il
regarde une
série je dis Netflix ça peut être
d'autres canaux mais voyez pr une vidéo
on a besoin de en citer d'autres pr une
vidéo Canut app TV voilà mais
ens il regarde les séries Jordan B c'est
pareil quand il va à un meeting quand il
va en déplacement dans le TGV il regarde
sa série et il peut la regarder juste à
5 minutes avant le meeting parce que
c'est un moyen soit décompresser soit
aussi de voilà de de de penser à autre
chose et après ils arrivent à se
concentrer très vite et ça c'est cette
nouvelle génération là qui semble plaire
aux Français qui voulait se
renouvellement et donc Marine Le Pen euh
la laa mis depuis longtemps je vous
coupe un instant car pardon parce que je
vous montre une image avant qu'elle
disparaisse c'est une image en direct de
Gérald daranin qui nomme aujourd'hui la
nouvelle directrice de la DGSI euh la
vie continue je voulais vous montrer
cette image avant qu'on l'ai plus c'est
pour ça que je vous ai coupé et j'en
profite pour
continuer mon propos sur Gérald armalin
est-ce que les altermement les
difficultés qu'on a connu depuis hier
sont la cause de ce ministre de
l'intérieur ou d'un certain ministre de
l'Économie est-ce qu'ils ont vraiment
bloqué Géral Gabriel Atal alors bloqué
non puisqu'il a été
nommé ils ont démenti les entourages ont
démenti le fait que Géral armanin et
Bruno Le Maire auraiit pu bloquer en
tant ronchonné contre cette nomination
il y en a deux autres qui sont cités
aussi c'est Richard Ferrand et et
François baayerou mais pourquoi alors
pourquoi aurait-il eux parce que je j'ai
compris ils ont aussi essayé de bloquer
Sébastien lecnu le Cornu d'accord je
l'entends c'est une ancienne
personnalité droite Gabriel Atal
pourquoi ça gêne baayrou et Ferand alors
ça gêne Baayou parce que comme je disais
tout à l'heure Baayou a n'a pas renoncé
à une ambition en 2027 il était
jusqu'ici le seul héritier d'Emmanuel
Macron pourord pour faire survivre l'axe
central puisqueon sait qu'edor Philippe
c'est plutôt le Paris à droite comme
Géral armanin voir Bruno le ma et là il
voit arriver sur ce même créneau Gabriel
Atal gabrielal qui a toujours dit
personne ne convient à Franois Baou
quand c'est trop à droite ça lui
convient pas quand c'est tropente ça lui
convient pas oui mais ça ça s'appelle la
politique saz en politique vous n'aimez
pas que d'autres arrivent est-ce que
c'est vraiment ça qui a bloqué qui a
empêché la nomination hier soir dans la
foulée c'est oui mais c'est très
particulier c'estàdire que au moment où
Elizabeth Bornem présente sa démission
on imagine qu'elle le fait parce que ça
y est Emmanuel Macron a choisi son
champion il n'allait pas laisser une
vacance et montrer que il y avait un
souci très particulier vous savez
Emmanuel Macron en 2022 avait choisi
Catherine Vautrin oui il avait eu un un
rendez-vous à l'Élysée
ou quasiment commenc à préparer
l'architecture du gouvernement et
finalement ça a été isab borne oui mais
Jean Castex nit pas encore démissionné
voyez ce que je veux dire on attendait
quand Catherine le nom de Catherine
Varin sortait était quasiment
officiel Jean cass c'était toujours
Premier ministre mais là il y a des gens
qui sont montés au créneau parce que le
nom de Gabriel est sorti assez
tard entre dimanche et lundi vous avez
aussi des gens sans forcément bloqué sur
le nom mais qui peuvent dire bah
attendez ça change la donne ça aurait
été Sébastien Lecornu ou Julien de
Normandie j'acceptais de rester à Bercy
ou à l'intérieur si c'est Gabriel Atal
je peux vouloir un portefeuille ou à
l'inverse vous m'avez promis leor mais
finalement je préfère rester à
l'intérieur si je pense que la prière
question àte sur la nouvelle nomination
de
Gabri lesançais dans l'ombre je suis m
j'ai voir le courage le travail le
sérieux des agents de DGS dans un
contexte extrêmement difficile pour
lequel évidemment le action et bien non
la première question ne porte pas sur
Gabri alors on continue on va Esser
d'écouter Gal parce qu'on envie de sair
qu'il en pense j'ai entendu j'ai lu et
après je vous libère Carl Guillaume
Tabar va nous rejoindre dans un instant
que certains ministres auraient vu comme
on le fait parfois dans certaines
entreprises avec Emmanuel Macron
d'accord nous on bloque pas mais en
revanche Gabriel Atal ne nous donne
aucun ordre on ne dépend que de vous
monsieur le Président est-ce que c'est
possible est-ce que vous avez des infos
en sens alors c'est très possible j'ai
pas d'infos particulière là-dessus mais
c'est déjà arrivé vous pensez pas
qu'Élisabeth
borne avait la main sur Bruno Le Maire
ah oui non non non non c'est comme ça de
toute façon sur la 5e République le
Premier ministre ne choisit pas son
gouvernement c'est le président de la
République au mieux le Premier ministre
peut choisir une ou deux personnalités
des proches voilà maximum euh évidemment
sauf en période de cohabitation oui mais
est-ce que ce serait vous pensez que
edit cresson elle a pu choisir les
ministres qui l'entourent non des noms
aussi François Fillon il a pas choisi ça
lui est imposé par le chef de l'État on
sait que le ministre de l'Intérieur oui
mais là là Emmanuel Macron a peut-être
besoin politiquement du poids de Bruno
Le Maire de Gérald armanin sauf que
c'est mettre des bâtons dans les roues
Gabriel Atal et de sa
politique non c'est pas mettre des
bâtons dans les roues c'est euh trouver
des équilibres vous savez euh on oublie
quelque chose parce que on a l'image du
d'Emmanuel Macron celle de 2017 celle de
de 2022 tout de suite après l'élection
présidentielle d'un président très
puissant le président de la 5e
République qui a tous les pouvoirs la
réalité c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron Macron
est un président contraint h il est
contraint par plusieurs choses d'abord
par sa majorité relative il ne peut plus
faire tout ce qu'il veut il est
contraint parce qu'il ne peut pas se
représenter et donc son pouvoir
s'amenuise au fur à mesure on s'approche
de 2027 et enfin il est contraint parce
qu'il a des alliés et des alliés qui lui
font valoir quoi François beou s'il veut
il peut lui dire mais nomme qui tu veux
mais moi si ça me convient pas mais 50
députés modem ils reprennent leur
liberté Gérald armanin il peut lui dire
pas de problème nomme qui tu veux moi je
retourne à l'Assemblée puis je vais me
constituer un groupe et puis ce groupe
là bah moi je considérerai qu'il sera
indépendant et Doncel Macron il est
obligé de jouer de de tenir compte de
ses contraintes il peut pas décider tout
seul donc il est obligé de les
convaincre d'entendre leurs arguments
d'entendre leur
récrimination et de leur proposer
quelque chose qui puisse leur convenir
on imagine un président tout puissant ça
c'est vrai quand il vient d'être élu et
qui distribue les postes mais là on est
dans un second mandat président qui ne
se représente pas qui n'a pas de
majorité absolue et à qui certains
peuvent jouer le rapport de faire jouer
le rapport de force Gérald Darmanin
parce qu'il faut désormais construire un
gouvernement ça peut prendre du temps ça
et ça on peut le comprendre un peu plus
parce qu'on sait qu'il faut comme vous
venez de N l'expliquer trouver un
équilibre faire des enquêtes sur chacun
c'est parfois alors il y a effectivement
il y a les enquêtes il y a dans les
équilibres on a oublié mais il y a
l'équilibre de la parité oui euh cette
parité avec Elizabeth borne à Matignon
elle était éclatante il y avait une
femme aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
il va donc falloir j'imagine si je ne
crois pas qu'Emmanuel Macron a changé de
ce point de vue-là il veut toujours un
gouvernement paritaire mais il va
falloir trouver des femmes mais
attention pas des femmes à liby pas des
femmes en secrétariat d'État ministère
délégué il y a un moment ça va finir par
se voir si dans les ministres régaliens
il y a aujourd'hi elisabe ne va pas
rester au gouvernement donc non ça va
être difficile de trouver des d'autant
plus que on on lit partout que isisabeth
borne a démissionné non elle a remis sa
démission vous vous souvenez la lettre
de démission d'éisabeth borne indique
bien que c'est pas elle qui qui est
partie oui ben tiens justement parce que
nous sommes en direct il est 12h52 vous
voyez Gérald armanin qui vient
d'officialiser aujourd'hui une nouvelle
directrice de la DGSI on attend une
réaction du ministre de l'Intérieur sur
la nomination de Gabriel hatal tiens
est-ce que c'est une question làdessus
il semble sourire je pense que chacun a
vu que je n'avais pas fini ma mission au
ministère de l'Intérieur et que je je ne
suis pas homme à me dérober quand il y a
des policiers des gendarmes des préfets
qui a quelques jours on est à 100 jours
du relais de la flamme on est à 200
jours des Jeux Olympique vont risquer
leur vie mettre leur réputation en jeu
moi je suis un homme d'honneur je suis
un homme de devoir et vous savez de là
où je viens d'une province une famille
populaire on aime bien terminer ce qu'on
fait voilà après il appartient au
président de la République de disposer
évidemment des postes ministériel je
suis à sa disposition mais je veux dire
au policiers aux gendarmes que je n'ai
pas l'habitude de compter sur un
quelconque avenir personnel lorsque je
les ai engagé dans une voie merci
beaucoup mer intéressant ce qu'il vient
de dire Gérald Armin non Carl mus c'est
au président de la République de décider
qui son ministre bah il a raison ou je
cyais que c'était moi je viens de lire
le gouvernement le communiqué de
l'Élysée a chargé Gabriel Atal de nommer
un nouveau gouvernement bah tiens donc
mais il va le faire il va présenter la
liste au président de la républi euh
s'il est novice bah il va dire je
choisis x xy et puis le président de la
République va le retocker puis il
recommencera et s'il est fin politique
ce qui est le cas il va savoir déjà ce
que veut Emmanuel Macron ce qui a été
Dilé et il présentera une liste où les
équilibres seront sont respectés voilà
après Gérald daranin bah voilà il est
beau joueur il sait qu'il était pas dans
la course cette fois-ci pour Matignon
parce que sur un échec y a moins d'un
mois voilà avec le projet de loi
immigration et donc pour l'instant il
pare le ministère de l'intérieur on va
voir si c'est toujours le cas on sait
que il y a peut-être des changements qui
pourraont intervenir en tout cas à
l'Élysée ils avaient appelé un grand
chambardement en il est fait à Matignon
est-ce qu'il a besoin d'aller plus loin
dans dans le gouvernement on verra
dernière question Carle parce qu'on nous
sommes devant l'hôtel de Matignon ou
dans quelques minutes théoriquement ça
va assez vite he après la nomination
d'un Premier minist il devrait y avoir
une passation il y aura une passation
nous savons pas encore à quelle heure on
va suivre tout particulièrement ce que
va dire Elizabeth bornne vous avez
commencé à évoquer son communiqué d'hier
où elle pr sa lettre de démission
d'hier assez différente de ce que font
les premiers ministres habituellement
hein on sentait une forme de peut-être
de rancune de déception alors et on va
suivre attentivement ce qu'elle dit là
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'elle a recopié en partie la démission
de Michel Rocard en 91 oui était pas
forcément le meilleur de Françis mitan
c'est François mitteran qui l'a poussé
dehors qui l'a fait sortir c'était une
sorte de cohabitation donc là elle a
fait comprendre aux Français que c'était
pas elle qui voulait partir c'était le
président qui a souhaité changer qui a
souhaitait avoir quelqu'un qui incarnait
ce nouveau souffle qui faut donné au
second canenard ce qu'il va falloir voir
dans les heures qui viennent c'est le
choix du directeur de cabinet à Matignon
c'est un poste essentiel c'est le rouage
un des quatre plus impant personnage de
l'État il y a les deux connus qui sont
le président de la République et le
Premier ministre et il y a les deux qui
sont dans l'ombre c'est le secrétaire
secrétaire général de l'ésée Al al CER
depuis 2017 le vice-président comme on
l'appelle vice-président et le directeur
de cabinet euh de Matignon est-ce que
lui Gabriel Atal va pouvoir le choisir
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui va être
imposé par l'Élysée on sait qu'en 2017
euh Emmanuel Macron avait essayé
d'imposer le directeur de cabinet à
edard Philippe il avait tenu bon il
avait réussi à imposer lui son choix
c'était ribado Duma est-ce que ça va
voilà c'est ça qu'il va falloir observer
maintenant évidemment vous avez raison
les passations de pouvoir mais passation
de pouvoir peut-être une ou deux phrases
mais c'est assez convenu malgré tout oui
bon ce sera quand même intéressantra ça
par parce que on comprendra mieux
quelles sont les relations entre
Elisabeth borne et Emmanuel Macron à mon
avis merci beaucoup Carl mus je vous
laisse retourner euh bah il faut écrire
le papier maintenantouour al alors tout
est chamboulé pour le figero magazine
vous faites la Une sur Gabriel Atal non
quand même pas mais euh il faut que je
fasse un papier sur lui donc évidemment
merci beaucoup Carle vous restez avec
nous on est là dans 3 minutes Guillaume
Tabar nous rejoint et on continue à
parler de cette nomination de Gabriel
tal oui le premier job mais qui va
prendre un peu de temps car vous le
savez à chaque fois dans ces momentsl il
faut respecter tout un T d'équilibre
d'équilibre politique géographique la
parité et on le sait Emmanuel Macron l'a
confié à des ministre de poids ces
derniers jours avant de prendre la
décision de remplacer ellizabeth borne
par Gabrielle et bien c'est de faire un
grand changement de qu'il y aura en gros
beaucoup de sortants pardonnez-moi dans
ce gouvernement donc l'idée
effectivement c'est de ne pas se
précipiter mais ce qui va arriver très
vite en revanche c'est la passation
pouvoir rentrer lisabeth borbe et
Gabriel hatal une face à son pouvoir
historique c'est le plus jeune ministre
de le plus jeune premier ministre de la
5e République et le lapsus est
intéressant parce que c'était aussi le
Premier ministre à être aussi jeune à
entrer au au sein du gouvernement puis
dernière chose quelques infos coulisses
que que Alison Tassan a pu se procurer
tout à l'heure et bien Gabriel Attal a
été reçu à l'Élysée pendant plus de 2
heures par Emmanuel Macron tout à
l'heure et donc c'est à ce moment
Gabriel Attal est le 26e Premier
ministre de l'histoire de la 5e
République il en est le plus jeune 34
ans et il succède donc à ellisabeth
Borne
ça bruit de couloir nous parvenait
depuis hier C officiel depuis un
communiqué qui est tombé il y a une
dizaine de minutes guillum bonjour
bonjour Thib alors est-ce que vous êtes
surpris bon est-ce que vous imaginiez il
y a une semaine que Gabriel Atal serait
Premier ministre aujourd'hui il y a une
semaine non non non pas qu'il estit
moins d'envergure ou moins de de
dimension politique que ceux dont on
citait également le nom he Sébastien LEC
Julen de Normandie mais je n'imaginais
pas pour une raison simple c'est que
venant d'arriver au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et réussant ayant
réussi à vraiment imprimer sa marque
immédiatement à ce poste et en adoptant
une une ligne une ligne très claire une
ligne assez assez audacieuse et d'emblé
assez efficace sur la laïité notamment
oui mais pas uniquement sur sur les
programmes sur l'autorité sur le le
redoublement sur l'expérimentation de
l'uniforme enfin il y de domaines comme
ça ce qui fait qu'on imagin pas mal que
ce travail à peine commencé il puisse
l'abandonner pour faire pour faire autre
chose je pense que c'était le principal
si ce n'est l'unique frein à sa
nomination mais Emmanuel Macron
visiblement a décidé de de passer outre
cet inconvénient en espérant que bah de
Matignon euh Gabriel Atal pourrait
continuer à incarner cette priorité pour
pour l'école on a beaucoup parlé avec
Carl mus de politique politicienne je
voudrais qu'on en vienne avec vous sur
le fond c'est quoi l'atalisme que va
faire Gabriel Atal parce que c'est pas
très clair pour l'instant on le connaît
on connaît ses positions sur certains
sujets récents hein depuis 6 mois à
l'éducation nationale mais
fondamentalement il pensent quoi quelle
est la vision de la société de Gabriel
Atal alors d'abord ça cet exercice qu'on
va faire beaucoup pour lui il faudrait
le faire pour tout responsablebles
politique savez c'est pas toujours
évident de de de d'adopter une
traçabilité
idéologique totale et surtout pour
quelqu'un qui qui est qui est aussi
jeune le chirakisme été très
évoluant le marconisme aussi le
sarcosisme aussi et bon Gabriel c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui est né à gauche oui
au PS dans le cabinet de Marie Touren
ministre de la Santé de François
Hollande cul dans le macronisme et qui
en fait tout en ayant cette cet héritage
initiale depuis qu'il est intervenu dans
le champ politique nationale ça a plutôt
été sur des positions alors j'ose pas
dire de droite parce que qu-ce ça dire
mais en tout cas sur une ligne insistant
sur la valeur du travail du Mérite dès
le début parce que son premier poste
c'est secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre de la Jeunesse hein ENF
ministre de l'éducation en charge de du
enfin ce qui sera peut-être le service
national universel ah tout de suite là
on est sur des positions assez claires
effectivement et il a porté cette idée
d'un service universel avec déjà le port
de de l'uniforme avec le respect de le
respect des couleurs avec le levé du
drapeau le respect des horaires donc sur
effectivement de de rétablissement de
l'autorité et de de de valorisation du
Mérite ensuite il était ministre délégué
au Budget et là encore il a annoncé
euh un plan sur la fraude parce qu'il
était moins euh exposé quand on au
budget c'est très un poste très
important mais les Français MOS oui mais
quand même il il a il a réussi à exister
en lançant un combat contre la fraude
oui la fraude fiscale d'un côté mais
aussi la fraude sociale de l'autre or on
sait bien que ça plutôt un sujet de
droite oui en tout cas çaataquit la
fraude sociale ça toujours été un tabou
à gauche et même la droite a été
toujours très prudente lorsqu'il
s'agissait de de de passer aux actes
alors lui il a pas eu le temps de non
plus de passer beaucoup aux actes c'est
peut-être aussi peut-être l'un de ses
soucis c'est que ministère du Budget il
a eu le temps de faire un budget et puis
il étéit promu à l'éducation nationale
là il a fait une rentrée scolaire et il
est déjà promu promu à Matignon voilà
doncain et puis alors il a été aussi
porte-parole mais quand on est
porte-parole on ne peut pas vraiment
proposer une idée et porter on porte les
sujets des on explique les sujets des
autres et les idées des autres mais pas
vraiment les siennes c'est ça mais
porte-parole sur la forme en tout cas il
a fait un sans faute on a vu on a connu
des des porte-paroles dimension voilà
qui qui qui qui parce que forcément il
s'agir de réagir en temps réel avec des
des des positions gouvernementales qui
peuvent parfois s un révélateur le
porte-parole c'est s un révélateur bon
et lui grégire n'a pas
réussi compliqué aussi bon lui Gabriel
Atal a fait a fait un un sans faute il
est à l'époque très proche de du premier
ministre Jean Castex on dis que c'était
un peu le Poulin de de Jean Castex alors
on se souvient de cette image incroyable
voilà au premier Conseil des ministres
Jean Castex qui était encore en train de
de former son gouvernement laissa
dépasser une feuille son lequel en
zoomant un peu les les photos prises on
voit je pense pas qu'il avait fait
exprès on ne sait PASF éta crit a-t-on
trouvé un OS àronger pour le jeune
Gabriel c'est entendu on a là une pépite
il faut quand même lui donner quelque
chose et bien en 3 ans à peine en 4 ans
bah le jeune Gabriel effectivement a a
fait du chemin et a montré qu'il savait
où il voulait aller alors on va voir
progressivement j'imagine parce qu'il va
assez rapidement donner une interview
souvent c'est comme ça que ça se passe
écoutez d'abord il y aura son son
message lors de la passion de pouvoir
oui dans quelques minutes VO on attend
alors petit détail
intéressant des très tôt ce matin 8h30
elabeth Bor a fait avait fait installer
les micros oui dans la cour de matigon
qu on inst les microos on dit tiens ça y
est c'est imminent or ça pris plus temps
que prévu et je pense c'est une manière
pour isisabeth de dire bah vous avez
voulu vous débarrasser de moi très bien
pour moi mission accomplie V terminé moi
je suis prête je suis prête à rendre les
clés
et isabe B a contribué à ce que toute la
matinée on ditende les micros sont prêts
il se passe toujours rien c'est qu'
quelque chose de pas normal
voilà c'est comme ça mainant est-ce que
c'est elle qui a accéléré finalement sa
démission parce que non vous vous pensez
pas que au final après être allé trois
fois en trois jours elle a dit Emmanuel
Macron bon maintenant je démissionne et
puis si tu as pas encore ton premier
ministre c'est pas mon problème parce
que pourquoi ça a traîné on imagine mal
isisabeth born démissionnait et Emmanuel
Macron validit cette démission sans
avoir le nom déjà ah ben on a vu que CIT
pas si simple que ça que plusieurs noms
enfin proposés en tout cas évoqués euh
avaent suscité des des hostilités euh
euh Sébastien lecorneu a suscité
l'hostilité de de de François baayrou
euh sans doute Alexis coller également
on disait encore jusqu'à ce matin que
bah la promotion Gabriel Atal d'abord
soit mécontentré un peu les poids lourds
que sont Bruno Le Maire ou Gabriel Atal
et ou Géral darana pardon ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dè hier soir euh
le les entourages de le maire et d'an
faisaiit bien savoir qu'il n'avait rien
contre Gabriel et qu' étaaiit tout à
fait prêt euh à travailler avec lui on
dit encore ce matin que peut-être
qu'Alexis ca n'était pas très chaud à à
cette perte là et que ça aura peut-être
des conséquences aussi sur la place de
l'xic cololaire dans dans le dispositif
on verra ça ah vous pensez que le bras
droit euh ultime d'Emmanuel Macron
pourrait être fragil encore comme pour
les riment tout est possible scolaire
peut rester à l'Élysée il peut quitter
l'Élysée il peut quitter l'Élysée pour
devenir ministre ça c'est déjà vu dans
le dans dans le passé bon en tout cas
sur la ligne pourenir votre question
initiale sur le message politique le
premier indice ce sera les quelques mots
que Gabriel LAL prononcera dans la cour
de Matignon lors de la passion de
pouvoir et ensuite c'est vrai vous
l'avez rappelé souvent le nouveau
Premier ministre est invité d'un 20h TF1
ou France 2 pour donner un peu sa sa sa
première sa première feuille de route en
quelque sorte voà et alors deux petites
questions guillum après je vous je vous
libère est-ce qu'il va rester ministre
de l'éducation nationale alors a priori
je dis à priori parce que bougé mais
hier soir à l'Élysée on me disait que
non oui que voilà fallait choisir euh il
y a un autre cas alors il y a eu un cas
historique Raymond bar qui nom à
Matillon av avait été ministre de de
l'économie bon mais plus récemment h
édard Philipp ah non édard Philippe
c'était l'intérime de Jard Colom c'était
vraiment inérime non mais la première
ministre sortante isabeth borne était
simultanément en charge du chantier de
la transition écologique avec bien sûr
deux ministres délégués mais
officialement c'était le ministre on a
vu en fait que personne en regardant
Elisabeth borne on voyait une première
ministre on voyait pas ah oui ça serait
ça effacerait presque le poste de de
ministre qui est un poste important ça
pour dire que quand un premier ministre
même symboliquement prend éventuellement
la ronsabilité d'un portefeuille précis
il faut quand même bien qu'il y a un
ministre délégué et au quotidien c'est
le Ministre délégé qui fait le Bou donc
je pense que ben je vous eneneis à ma
deuxième question va-t-il rester
ministre de
l'écologie Gabal oui va-t-il rester
Premier ministre et ministre de la
transition écologique en tout cas il y
aura effectivement à définir les
priorités de cette étape on peut penser
que l'écologie va en rester une mais
comme la jeunesse et l'école aussi oui
moi spontanément mais c'est c'est pas
c'est pas une information c'est une une
déduction je pense que gabrielal va être
Premier ministre et que l'on va nommer
un un ou une ministre de l'éducation
nationale et un ou une ministre de
l'écologie sachant pour l'instant il y a
deux titulaires l'écologie il y a
christop Béchu plus les aspects
effectivement de transition écologique
et Anas P et plus sur les question
énergétique effectivement la dimension
économique bon je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
terme de visibilité du du de la priorité
ça ça a donné tous les fruits que l'ont
pouvait attendre et peut-être ça c'est
qu'un qu'une suggestion enfin une une
déduction en tout cas peut-être que
Emmanuel Macron et Gabriel Atal voudront
nommer un ou une patron unique du du
portefeuille de l'écologie merci
beaucoup Guillaume Tabar bon on va
écouter ce que dit Gabriel Atal on va
aussi écouter ce que dit isabeth bord ça
va être intéressant de voir quels sont
sest ses relations peut-être tendu avec
Emmanuel Macron au vu du communiqué que
nous avons pu lire hier merci beaucoup
Guillaume avec donc donc cette
demiurprise puisque nous y attendions
depuis hier mais Gabriel hatal et ce
premier effet wa vous aussi vous trouvez
que c'est un un
nom on insiste beaucoup sur la jeunesse
de Gabriel at mais c'est pas que ça
c'est aussi depuis depuis un mois
l'homme politique français le plus
populaire à égalité voire dans certains
cas dev depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que les Français ont
attendu autant de choses d'une
personnalité politique depuis 2017 non
et et on a jamais vu je crois que le
dernier cas c'était Nicolas Sarkozi au
ministère de l'intérieur on a jamais vu
un ministre en ESPE de 3 mois
s'installer en tête des baromètres de de
popularité donc Gabriel Atal arrive avec
un capital personnel important on disait
beaucoup qu'Emmanuel Macron voulait des
collaborateurs à Matignon et qu'il avait
choisi Philippe Jean castexabeth B des
gens qui n'avaient pas de ni notoriété
ni capital politique personnelle avant
d'entrer à matigon dans le cas de
Gabriel Atal c'est différent merci
Guillaume nous restons en direct vous
laisse avec ces images devant matin
alors pour l'instant elles ne sont pas
très intéressantes mais promis d'ici
quelques minutes quelques heures
peut-être il y aura une passation
derrière ces grilles et nous suivrons
tout ça très attentivement merci de nous
suivre excellente après-midi sur le Figo
live
j'ai pas de retour il est peut-être pas
allumé je l'avais pas allumé mon
retour
je l'ai allumé mais c'est
bon dans quelques minutes Gabriel Atal
sera officiellement Premier ministre il
prendra ses fonctions à l'hôtel de
Matignon les images en direct depuis la
résidence le bureau du Premier ministre
c'est toujours un grand moment de notre
démocratie une passation de pouvoir
entre deux premier ministres oui bien
sûr ça sera si je ne m'abuse le 26 le
26e Premier ministre donc effectivement
depuis
1958 beaucoup d'eau ont coul sous les
ponts il y a effectivement une espèce de
protocole de cérémonial mais
enfin les temps ont changé les modes ont
changé donc là on va voir sortir la
deuxième femme qui a été premierre
ministre sous la 5e République c'était
quand même pas beaucoup hein deux femmes
sur 26 c'est pas énorme la grande
originalité c'est l'entrée à Matignon
d'un homme très jeune du plus jeune de
la 5e République puceque euh Laurent
Fabius en 1984 était très jeune il avait
36 ans je crois là il a 34 ans euh euh
c'est un garçon qui manque pas
d'expérience néanmoins
puisqueab il est d'abord engagé en
politique depuis très longtemps et
deuxièmement il connaît les ministères
puisqu'il a déjà été il a déjà occupé
trois ministères en fait il a été au
budget il a été porte-parole du
gouvernement il
a aussi occupé le le le le ministère de
l'éducatione qu'il a été aussi
secrétaire d'État également au tout
début de sa jeune carrière VO ça fait
partie des trois euh bien sûr mais oui
ça fait TR plus le porte-parole c'est ça
ouais ou oui euh donc non c'est c'est
c'est c'est une un homme qui qui est est
je dirais précoce en toute circonstances
alors maintenant ça va être une autre
paire de manche parce que Premier
ministre c'est autre chose il faut à la
fois bah impulser une un certain élan il
faut
euh arriver à être complémentaire du du
président de la République qui n'est pas
tou ce qui est loin d'être évident il y
a peu de couples finalement exécutif ti
d'ailleurs on saurait ti lesquels ont
vraiment marché est-ce que Sarkozy
Fillon ça marchait 5on peut dire ce
qu'on peut dire ce qu'on peut dire ce
qui a marché vraiment c'est au début en
tout les cas de GO Pompidou au début au
début ce qui a marché c'est Pompidou
Mesmer ouais ça ça a marché alors là
vous me par vraiment des tout
premardestin re bbard aussi ça a marché
un peu
euh mitteran avec avec avec Morrois non
parce que ça très vite
Morrois essayé de dire an qu' fallait
changer de politique et justement
instaurer la politique de la rigueur ça
s'est pas fait sans mal il y a eu il y
avait des clans à l'intérieur de de
l'exécutif à ce moment-là donc non c'est
c'est c'est loin d'être
évident soit le président et est très
lointain et le Premier ministre se sent
pas tellement soutenu soit au contraire
le Premier ministre estime que le
président est trop présent ce qui est le
cas maintenant on va le dire depuis le
quinquena notamment et depuis Nicolas ou
voà c'est un peu le cas aussi de franis
Holland qui est vraiment trèsès franoll
Emmanuel Macron qui est très très
présent qui laisse peu d'air à son
premier ministre et c'est aussi le
reproche qu' lui a fait d'ailleurs c'est
pas prendre la hauteur qui était celle
qui était voulue par le président de GA
quand la 5e République a été créée
c'està-dire un président au-dessus
du qui a son domaine réservé entre la
politique la politique étrangère et puis
quelques dossiers importants de
politique
régalienne le Premier ministre
appliquant l'article 20 de la
Constitution qui consiste à conduire la
politique du
gouvernement mais bon tout ça ce sont
des textes ce sont des théories et en
fait ce sont les hommes qui font la
politique et les hommes et les femmes
bien sûr et on va voir comment là ça
peut s'articuler sachez que Gabriel Atal
arrive à pied malgré le grand froid dans
quelques instants à l'El c'est pas très
loin vous avez commencé tiens ça m'a
surpris la première chose que vous avez
d lorsqu'on a ouvert ce live c'est on va
voir sortir une femme parce que c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de gabrielleal
tout à l'heure on va bien être obligé de
dire un mot d'éizabeth born et on va
être très attentif à ce qu'elle dit
parce que hier son communiqué il était
un peu
salé son communiqué d' lettre de
démission oui on l'a
dit on l'a comparé à celle de Michel
recard don on connaissait l'inimitié
entre Michel Rocard et et François V oui
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire bon là
président de la républ et sa première
ministre s'entendait pas vraiment très
bien enfin il y avait des je dirais il y
avait pas tellement de symbiose entre
les deux elle est vraimentlit elle est
amère non mais elle est amère parce que
bah elle a fait le travail certes elle
est pas drôle elle est assez technocrate
dans son comportement c'est une
technicienne c'est une femme de de de de
compétence hein faut le dire elle a
quand même rempli la mission
c'est-à-dire que elle a fait passer
plusieurs lois et notamment deux d'entre
elles qui sont je dirais qui resteront
dans le l'histoire de ce début de
quinena c'est-à-dire l'augmentation du
départ de l'âge à la retraiteou bien 64
ans et puis la loi sur l'immigration
elle aé difficile mais ses lois sont
passé elle a essuyé quand même beaucoup
de tempêtes politiques et social et elle
s'en est plutôt bien tirée donc on peut
critiquer mais néanmoins c'est quelqu'un
qui a qui a assuré la mission qui a fait
le job et qui n'a je dirais pas créé et
pas provoqué à une une occasion prês
peut-être quand elle a critiqué quand
elle a dit qu'elle ne recourrait plus au
493 ce qui était une bêtise de dire ça
alors que c'est dans la Constitution et
qu' en avaitment besoin par avait pas de
majorité relative parce que c'est ça
aussi la grande particularité de cette
pr minist c'est que cette première
ministre a gouverné avec une majorité
relative bien
sûr elle sera la
deuxè 2è Premier ministre Premier
ministre à avoir utilisé le plus souvent
le 493 après Michel recard et celle qui
aurait essuyé le plus de motion
également de censure tout écarté une qui
est passée pas loin lors de la réforme
al alors oui oui oui une qui est passé
pas loin lors de la la réforme des
retraite donc elle a elle a pas connu je
dirais une période très facile hein
c'est c'est c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire elle a été assez chahutée et elle
est restée toujours néanmoins droit dans
ses boottes Gabriel Atal on voit les
caméras qui s'agitent derrière dans la
rue derrière vous le voyez Yve et
Gabriel Atal qui devrait surgir d'un
instant à l'autre dans la cour de cet
hôtel de Matignon le voici le nouveau
Premier ministre est-ce que c'est le
premier effet waouou depuis depuis
l'élection de d'Emmanuel Macron 201 oui
parce qu'il y en a pas eu beaucoup des
fait waou madame madame Bor n'était pas
un effet waou c'était d'ailleurs celle
qui était pas elle était pas vraiment
prévue à ce moment-là ça a été plutôt un
2è voire un trè choix et Gabriel Atal
lui c'est un effet waou parce que par
qu'il est très jeune il est très jeune
parce que il est il est populaire
néanmoins il est connu il populaire
alors que Madame Bor n'était pas très
connu lui il est populaire il est tous
les sondages le montrent que les euh que
les que les gens interrogés soient de
droite ou de gauche il est plutôt assez
apprécié et puis et puis il est très
jeune quand même 34 ans c'est un âge où
il y en a encore quelques-uns parmi les
Français qui commence tout juste à
travailler hein quand bon donc faut
quand même souligner ça c'est quand même
très très jeune Gabriel Atal qui
patiente il est voilà il est juste là je
pense qu'il attend et le voici le
nouveau Premier ministre qui avance et
ellisabeth bornne doit être pas loin
est-elle au bout du oui elle est là elle
est sur le Peron froid oui et c'est
toujours un moment symbolique on essaie
de s'impréer de l'ambiance peut-être
qu'on va entendre Yve ce que se disent
les premiers ministres
ouais il peut-être d'abord la voir c'est
ça ils vont se voir un instant bureau
avant qu'elle ne attendez ah bah non
elle est là elle est là ouais ils sont
ici et euh et il y a pas les micro la
photo non il y a pas les micros alors ce
qui veut dire queils vont se voir avant
c'est ça Guillaume Tabar nous disait ce
matin qu'il y avait eu peut-être une un
petit message fait passer par Elisabeth
borne qui avait fait installer ses deux
micros ce matin comme pour dire moi je
suis prête he vous m'avez dit de partir
je suis prête qu'est-ce qui se passe ou
oui oui oui oui bah c'était oui tout ça
c'est du petit jeu euh effectivement
elle a peut-être essayé de de de
d'accélérer et de perturber le président
de la République mais qui est pas
perturbable en l'occurrence c'est pas
intimidé et puis je vois pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'il sera intimidé d'ailleurs
mais elle pensait peut-être aussi que la
nomination de Gabriel Atal qui a petit-
dééjeuné avec le président de la
République ce matin pendant 2h que ce
petit déjeuner
serait suivi d'une annonce immédiate or
l'annonce n'a pas eu lieu tout de suite
la preuve c'est que le le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ou l'ex-ministre
de l'éducation national il a continué à
faire le boulot à faire son job bah il a
continué à faire le job puisquil avait
un rendez-vous par misio avec du
personnel de de l'éducation nationale
c'est une conférence qui a dû durer 1
heure et de infini interminable
temp il pas né prier ministre iléomé
prier
ministreo ver 12h15 quelque chosee ça
alors si çaait été à la période de
François Holland que n'auraiton pas dit
mais c'est quoi cette amateurisme que
font-il ils sont incapables de nommer un
Premier ministre et le futur premier
ministre continue à faire des
conférences de
press n'est pas très important en fait
ce qui est important c'est savoir quels
sont les choix qui sont fait ement on
peut critiquer la forme la méthode tout
ce qu'on veut mais c'est les choix qui
sont faits est-ce que là c'est un choix
c'est un choix qui est très clair là
quand
mêmeyal c'est pas bon c'est c'est c'est
c'est ça veut dire quelque chose ça il
a bon il prend quelqu'un de confiance s
coute quelqu'un qui monte dans l'opinion
quelqu'un qui a d'énergie de de l'Alan
et de l'élan et
euh et donc il veut aussi de marquer les
esprits c'est évident c'est pas c'est
pas quelqu'un qui laisse indifférent euh
alors on va évidemment essayer
d'analyser parce qu' il y a deux points
parti politique politicienne qui nous
intéressent ceux qui ont fait de la
résistance ceux qui rêvent de devenir
président ceux qui et puis il y a le
concret c'est quoi l'atalisme parce que
ça y est on peut commencer à utiliser ce
mot non mais faut pas faut pas utiliser
ce mot là parce comme le reste
d'ailleurs comme maronisme et tout ça
c'est quelle est la vision la société de
Gabriel Atal que va-t-il faire que
peut-il tenter d'imposer c'est quelqu'un
qui est assez manéable c'est n sommes
tout donc de toute manière on va
apprendre à le connaître mais oui
puisque il vient de la gauche il a été
éduqué je dirais dans une gauche
d'ailleurs plutôt intello bobo très
citadine
euh nouvelle gauche comme aurait dit
mitan la deuxème gauche oui la deè
gauche euh il a été élevé dans ce
milieuà il a rejoint il a rejoint
Emmanuel Macron après avoir fait du
cabinet puce qu'il a été membre du
cabinet de Marisol Touren au ministère
de la Santé sous François Hollande euh
mais Marisol Touren était dans cette
veine de gauche citadine très éduqué
c'était quand même la fille d'Alain
Touren grand intellectuel s'il en est
normalien sociologue euh donc c'est
quand même un milieu où on est où on a
fréquenté les grandes écoles lui il a
fréquenté l'écoleacienne qui est aussi
un sy sûr avec cette archive qu'on voit
DEP un creusé un creusé de de cette
gauche citadine il a fait sciencep donc
il a fait du cabinet et puis il est
devenu ministre très jeune puisque il
avait pas 30 ans quand il a commencé à
servir le président de la République
voilà donc mais néanmoins quand il est
arrivé donc c'est quelqu'un qui qui a
fait très peu de faute quand il était
porte-parole quasiment pas de faute ce
qui est pas simple et donc il a réussi à
épouser
finalement la dialectique de son
président de la République et puis quand
il est arrivé au ministère de
l'Éducation bah il a aussi fait preuve
de fermeté d'autorité ce qu'on lui
demandait et finalement il
était c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
plaît aussi bien à la droite qu'à la
gauche et la droite est plutôt assez
élogieuse à son endroit parce que bah il
est c'est c'est c'est l'anti nï si vous
voulez c'est il va encore plus loin que
blancire tout de suite il a fait preuve
d'autorité sans passer par la loi
d'ailleurs en passant par la voie
réglementaire ou les circulaires bon il
s'est opposé à la baaya il a milité pour
ou il milite pour l'uniforme à l'école
il s'était occupé du service universel
aussi euh donc il est il est les idées
il a montré qu'il avait les idées assez
claires là-dessus c'est plutôt une école
républicaine Bontin qui défend aura-t-il
les mains libres plus que les autres
Emmanuel Macron fait un choix en nommant
pour la première fois un Premier
ministre qui a un vrai poids politique
Édouard Philippe n'en avait pas au
moment de sa nomination quasiment pas a
pris de
l'envergure les années passants mais
Jean Castex et ellisabeth born n'avaient
pas cette stature la stature qui a
aujourd'hui Gabriel LAL malgré son jeune
âge est-ce qu'il aura un statut
particulier par rapport aux trois
précédents non mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il ait un point politique moi on TR
il oui mais c'est quelqu'un de populaire
connu des Français c'est déjà pas mal
ouis mais je sais pas sil a un poid
politique pour autant on peut quelqu'un
qui a un point politique c'est quelqu'un
qui a des troues qui des supporters qui
a des soutiens c'est pas son cas pas
encore je crois pas bon ce qui va se
passer c'est que on peut s'attendre à
quelqu'un qui
soit très proche quand même du président
de la République c'est un peu un bébé
Macron c'est un peu une photocopie de
Macron c'est d'ailleurs ça peut être un
cap parce que l'avantage qu'avait
quelqu'un comme Jean Castex c'est qu'il
était il était complémentaire de
deemmanuel Macron Jean Castex c'était
quelqu'un qui sentait bon la province
qui qui avait son accentamp r V voilà
qui qui qui qui qui avait une façon de
s'exprimer de s'habiller même qui était
un peu différente et donc ça pouvait
plaire à une bonne partie des Français
il y avait un côté complémentaire là
pour ce qui est de du Premier ministre
qui vient d'être nommé il est quand même
très très comparable à Macron il est
très jeune très propre sur lui euh bon
ne dites pas que Jean Castex n'était pas
propre sur lui que j'ai voulu dire mais
il avait pas il avait pas la patine si
vous voulez qu'avait Jean Castex qui
avait quand même quelques qui avait
roulé sa bosse si vous me permettez
l'expression on vient de voir les les
micros qui viennent d'être installés au
pied des marches de cet hôtel de
Matignon et donc Gabriel Atal et
Elisabeth borne devrai s'exprimer dans
dans un instant il y a un gouvernement a
former iltrard ça on sait que ça peut
prendre du temps et c'est normal oui
alors là ça peut prendre du temps
effectivement parce que bon alors on
sait maintenant on l'a dit qu'il y avait
quelques réticence à la nomination de
gabrielal alors d'ailleurs ça m'a
étonnéintérieur même du
gouvernement parce que il y avait
peut-être des jalousies parce que il y
avait peut-être aussi quelques ministres
qui se
considérit d'une légitimité supérieure
pour occuper le poste Premier ministre
parce que il y a des premiers il y a des
ministres de taille qui se disent bon on
va être gouverné par un gamin bon a ch
est- qu' est vrai j'ai lu que certains
ministres avaient très clairement dit
Emmanuel Macron ne s'opposera pas en
revanche on ne dépend pas de lui on ne
dépend que de vous monsieur le
présidentou on va voir à l'expérience on
va voir comment ça se passe j'ai posé la
question ce matin car qui me dit vous
croyez vraiment que Bruno Lemer et Géral
armanin référé à éizabeth Borne et qu'il
ne passait pas directement par AI ce qui
était vrai aussi mais bon il y a a
quelqu'un qui a fait acte d'allégance
pas pas au Premier ministre mais qui qui
veut rester c'est apparemment c'est
Gérald Arman qui a dit qu' voulait
continuer son
travailendtin verra on verra de toute
manière la composition du gouvernement
elle est largement du pouvoir elle
dépend largement du pouvoir
discrétionnaire du président de la
République c'est bien rare
que vous ayez un ministre qui soit un
ministre qui soit nommé contre la vie du
président de la République al sachez que
ce matin gerér c'était très intéressant
parce qu'il nommait la nouvelle
présenter la nouvelle directrice de la
DGSI et c'est en marche de cette annonce
qu'il a s'est retrouvé devant les micros
qu'il a dû commenter l'arrivée de
Gabriel Atal et il n'a pas dit j'attends
les décisions du Premier ministre qui
aura la charge de nom il a dit j'attends
les décision du Président de la
République qui aura la charge ministres
c'est une bonne guerre mais en plus le
pouvoir du Premier ministre on a coutume
de dire
qu'aujourd'hui depuis l'instauration du
quinquena et puis la pratique notamment
la pratique de Nicolas Sarkozy et
d'Emmanuel Macron et bien le pouvoir du
prier
non mais c'est sans doute anecdotique
mais c'est intéressant parce que
quelques minutes avant c'est plus un
collaborateur c'est plus communiqu
cabinet directeur de cabinet le
communiqué publié quelques minutes avant
exprime bien Emmanuel le président de la
République a chargé Gabriel Atal de
nommer un gouvernement Gérald armanin
lui dit j'attends les décisions du
président de la républque ou alors on va
voir on va voir effectivement c'est ce
qui est sûr c'est que si vous voulez le
le pouvoir du Premier ministre
aujourd'hui est sans doute inférieur à
celui qu'il était temps de de George
Pidou sous le général de Gaulle parce
que le général de Gaulle vous l'avez
jamais vu s'occuper des contrats de
leasing automobile ce que fait le
président de la République actuelleoui
vous l'avez jamais vu non plus faire un
une vidéo pour dire de faire du sport
par que c'est le rôle du président vu le
président de Gaulle j'étais déjà là
pourtant sortir d'une salle de
sporté j'étais déj né moi et donc donc
donc vous voyez la la mais bon c'est les
époques qu' ont changé on va pas non
plus être nostalgique de ce qui pas
voilà c'est c'est c'est une autre époque
un gouvernement à composé vous me dites
que Gérald armanin et oui il a annoncé
qu'il voulait ce matin continuer son
travail au ministère de l'Intérieur
ministère intéressant surtout à quelques
mois des Jeux Olympiques et les autres
Bruno Le Maire que va-t-il faire lui ce
ministre très important alors il y av
une grosse interrogation sur Bruno Le
Maire on va voir effectivement Bruno Le
Maire on disait mais il faut toujours se
méfier des on disait que le Président de
la République l'aurait bien vu comme
pe-être de liste aux Européennes pour la
majorité présidentielle ce qui était
quand même assez peu probable que le
prés que le ministre de de de l'économie
accepte cela c'est une façon d'être
relégué et puis il y avait d'autres
personnage de l'ombre aussi qui pouvait
être rétisant on parlait beaucoup de
Alexis coller qui est le secrétaire
général quelqu'un qui n'est pas connu
mais quelqu'un qui est très important on
dit c'est le viceésident on dit que
c'est le viceprésident un peu comme Gan
l'était sous euh Sarkozy et Alexis Caire
on dit on dit aussi mais ça reste
confirmé qu'il était plutôt assez
dubitatif sur la pertinence d'e
nomination pourquoi
Lux parce que voilà il estimait
peut-être que la la la la compétence je
ve dire l'expérience plutôt pas la
compétence l'expérience de àal était
peut-être un peu tendre bon tout ça on
verra tout ça va se va
seah va s'éclaircir d'ici
alors ça peut prendre du temps c'estàd
que il est pas évident du tout qu'on
connaisse le gouvernement aujourd'hui
sans doute
d'ailleurs ça serait déjà très bien
qu'on qu'on le connaisse d'ici à la fin
de la semaine ah oui carrément oui ou ou
moi j'ai le souvenir d'un gouvernement
morroi 1 en 1981 ça avait pris
énormément de temps pourquoi parce que
quand vous constiuez un gouvernement il
faut que vous respectiez des équilibres
politique donc il pour faire simple il
va falloir quelques ministes du MoDem
pour Franois qu ministizon PHPP quelques
ministes potentiellement venu de la
droite pour
voilà hommes femes des jeunes des plus
expérimentés enin voyez il y a toute une
et en plusajoute maintenant la la Haute
autorité qui contrôle alors
effectivement il faut contrôler le
patrimoine de chacun des intéressés pour
savoir si c'est compatible s'il y a pas
de conflit d'intérêt et si les uns et
les autres sont en conformité avec avec
la loi et
plusieurs questions sur la composition
de ce gouvernement Bruno Le Maire donc
on en a parlé Gérald armanin aussi quand
on fait un coup comme celui-là en nomant
un
ministre qui nous interpelle qui nous
donne envie d'en voir plus est-ce qu'il
faut changer une grande partie du du
gouvernement est-ce qu'il faut tout
renouveler est-ce qu'il faut mettre non
alors comme les fait si vous me
permettez l'expression waouou existe
avec ce premier ministre c'est peut-être
une obligation en moins c'estàd de de de
de
faire sur l'image de Gab de créer la
surprise avec d'autres des ministres qui
arrivent qui dont on s'attendait
absolument pas à la nomination on va
voir la la la la grande la grande
marotte je dirais des des présidents de
la République successives souvent
c'était d'aller chercher des
personnalités fortes de la société
civile bon on se souvient de Dupon
Moretti pour pour la justice Emmanuel
Macron avait eu Nicolas hullo il y a si
on peut contester d' ça faisait souvent
chez les sportifs pour le ministère des
Sports souvent oui oui non mais pas
uniquement
maiselqu un grand médecin ou alors un
grand avocat bon on va voir on va voir
si là cette fois c'est encore une chose
qui pourrait être pratiqué
euh on verra il y il y avait il y a eu
des journalistes aussi je vous rappelle
que Françoise Girou on vous a éé été
vous prendriez quel ministère tiens quel
est votre poid politique
qui question parce que il y a un poste
qui se libère c'est celui du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale est-ce que
est-ce qu'il pourrait rester alors c'est
pas incompatible c'estàd que le premier
ministre peut occuper je vous rappelle
que Raymond bar par exemple a occupé
Matignon et le ministère des Finances
euh c'est arrivé que il cumule il
pourrait être encore ministre de
l'Éducation parce que c'est une fonction
qui semblait lui plaire à laquelle il
était attaché dans laquelle il
commencait à voir
bah résults son succès lui aurait
peut-être coûté le le a failli lui
coûter le poste parce qu'il y a une
semaine on se disait non il va pas
débarquer à tal de l'éducation nationale
on va voir on va voir si non à mon avis
le plus probable c'est qu'il nomme un
nouveau ministre d'éducation nationale
mais faudra trouver dans la m on peut on
peut quand on est premier ministre
occuper un autre une autre fonction
est-ce qu'il va rester ou être ministre
de l'écologie parce que c'était le cas
d'Élisabeth borne elle était première
ministre et en charge de la transition
écologique c'est c'était peut-être assez
clair avecabeth Bor qui était déjà
minist av un ministre délégué chargé de
la transition écologique elle avait
effectivement dans son dans ses dans ses
missions comme mission prioritaire la
transition écologique on va voir ça tout
ça c'est ce qu'on saura une fois que le
Président de la République parce que le
Président de la République donnerit
rendez-vous à la nation est-ce que ça va
être pour fixer justement des grandes
orientations de ce ce ce ce ce
gouvernement ce gouvernement àal il y a
le discours de politique générale
du du Premier ministre ce sera après la
la nomination de son gouvernement hein
ça normalement oui c'est après la
nomination du gouvernement parce qu'il
peut engager sa sa responsabilité
d'ailleurs après son discours de
politique
général on
verraabeth B ne l'avait pas fait ne
l'avait pas fait on verra ce qui ce
qu'il fait ça va être assez intéressant
de voir les les les les jours à venir
sont pleins d'incertit
évidemment je vous rappelle que nous
sommes en direct avec y treard il est
14h49 cette passation de pouvoir devait
débuter à 14h30 Gabriel Atal est arrivé
à l'heure mais il s'entretient en ce
moment même avec ellisabeth born à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel de matinon vous
voyez c'est deux micros qui ont été
placés au pied des marches de matigon
dans la cour où se presse autour on l'a
vu tous les personnel les gens qui trava
i il y a une partie du personnel qui va
certainement rester dans qui va rester à
matigon et puis vous avez des membres du
cabinet alors là une équipe plus
restreinte qui généralement sont là
parce qu'ils sont attachés plus
particulièrement non pas à la fonction
mais à la personne qui occupe cette
fonction et qui d'ailleurs ont été
appelés à cette fonction parce que parce
que c'était eux et parce que c'était
elle surveille les portes avec ses
huissiers qui s'approchent et on se dit
qu'à tout moment le la première ministre
sortante et bien ils sont là on voit
cette porte qui s'ouvre on imagine que
Gabriel Atal et ellizabeth born vont
bientôt surgir pour
prononcer leur derniers mots dans le cas
d'éliisabeth BN sera très intéressant
suite à sa lettre de démission assez
particulière hier et les premiers mots
donc de de Gabriel Atal Gabriel Atal 28
ans euh 34 ans qui devient le 26e
Premier ministre de la 5e République
gouvernement pour la première fois à
l'âge de 28 ans c'est ça et beaucoup de
commentaires dans le chat y et je vous
couperai évidemment si s'ils sont là
parle de l'âge pour contrer un certain
Jordan
Bardella est-ce qu' oui alors il y a
cette dimension effectivement ils sont
là écoutez voà on en parlera tout à
l'heure il a été choisi aussi peut-être
comme une arme anti Bardella aux
élections
européennes monsieur le prier ministre
ch
Gabriel bienvenue à
au moment où je te passe le relais je
voudrais d'abord dire toute ma
reconnaissance ma reconnaissance au
président de la République bien sûr qui
m'a fait confiance depuis
2017 et je suis Fiè d'avoir à ses côtés
pendant près de 7 ans servi notre pays
et nos concitoyens en tant que ministre
puis Premier
ministre gouvernemental que j'ai eu
l'honneur de
diriger qui a porté avec force et
détermination les réformes
nécessaires y compris les plus
difficiles et je veux vraiment dire un
grand merci à chacune et à
chacun je veux dire ma reconnaissance
aussi aux parlementaires de la majorité
dans un contexte
inédit souvent face aux attaques les
plus brutal ils ont
tenu alors je serai bientôt l'une
d'entre eux en tant que député du
Calvados et je me réjouis de continuer à
servir mon pays à leur côté avec
détermination
et
exigen et puis je veux remercier aussi
les parlementaires des
oppositions qui ont fait le choix du
dialogue et du
compromis plutôt que du blocage et de
l'obstruction je tiens aussi à remercier
toutes les administrations que j'ai
dirigé au cours de ces 7
années les équipes de Matignon et tout
particulièrement mon
cabinet je mesure le travail qu'ils ont
accompli à toute heure du jour et
souvent de la nuit et j'ai été
particulièrement bien entouré donc je
veux leur dire un grand
merci je veux également rendre
hommage à tous les
partenaires qui sont
essentiel pour notre action au service
du pays je p P aux élus locaux qui
s'engagent au quotidien pour nos
concitoyens je pense aux acteurs de la
société civile et notamment aux
associations qui portent des combats
essentiels de la transition écologique à
l'égalité des chances et puis je pense
aux partenaires sociaux avec lesquels
j'ai toujours entretenu des relations de
confiance et de
moi je crois au
dialogue à la
coconstruction à la force du collectif
alors il y a eu des moments difficiles
mais le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu enfin je veux dire aux françaises
et aux
Français que chaque jour en tant que
ministre puis Premier
ministre j'ai mis toute mon énergie à
les
servir j'ai travaillé sans
relâche sans chercher les coups
d'éclat et
partir du réel vécu par nos concitoyens
partir de leur quotidien et chercher à
apporter des résultats rapides et
tangibles c'est ma méthode d'action et
je
l'assume alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ministre cher
Gabriel j'ai parlé de
reconnaissance et je veux aussi parler
de
fierté je suis fier du travail accompli
au cours de ces presque 20 mois pendant
lesquels je me suis en particulier dans
des conditions inédites à l'Assemblée
atteler à faire adopter nos budgets la
réforme des
retraites la loi immigration est plus de
50 textes pour répondre aux défis de
notre pays et aux attentes de nos
concitoyens nous avons réussi à
construire des majorités de projets dans
l'esprit du dépassement porté par le
Président de la République en
2017 et puis je suis fier aussi que
notre pays soit désormais doté d'une
planification
écologique concrète
et
solide tout au long de ces années tout
au long de ces mois je n'ai jamais
reculé devant aucun
obstacle je n'ai jamais reculé devant
aucune
réforme j'ai mené les projets qui me
semblaient justes et nécessaires pour
notre pays et j'ai tenu sans trembler le
cap fixé par le président de la
République enfin bien sûr je ressens
aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'humilité je suis consciente de tout ce
qui reste à
accomplir je connais les enjeux devant
nous nous devons y répondre et
rassembler nous devons plus que jamais
veiller à donner sa chance et des
perspectives à
chacun bâtir une France plus forte
et plus juste dans une Europe plus
souveraine Monsieur le Premier Ministre
cher
Gabriel au moment où je te passe le
relais je suis
confiante nous nous connaissons bien
tous les deux nous nous sommes engagés
dès la première heure derrière le
président de la
République tu as la détermination et
l'énergie pour mener une équipe et
porter les projets nécessaires pour
notre
pays tu as aussi cette volonté de tenir
de respecter la parole
donnée en te sachant dans cette fonction
j'ai confiance et je t'adresse tous mes
vœux de succès tu peux compter sur moi
pour t'y aider il en va de de la
réussite de notre pays et c'est
finalement la seule chose qui compte et
peut-être je je voudrais terminer sur un
mot plus
personnel en prenant mes fonctions
j'avais adressé un message à toutes les
petites
filles en leur disant d'aller au bout de
leurs
rêvees je pense que mon parcours
démontre que quel que soit son
histoire tout est
possible mais j'ai aussi pu
mesurer assez souvent qu'il reste du
chemin pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes alors je le dis à toutes
les femmes tenez bon l'avenir vous
appartient et puis plus largement il
reste du
chemin pour que
chacun quel que soit son
origine quel que soit son milieu
social quel que soit son
adresse et toutes ses chances par son
mérite et son
talent alors à toutes et tous je veux le
dire à vos côtés je continuerai le
combat je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie
madame la Première ministre très chère
Élisabeth mesdames messieurs depuis
1936 depuis lon Bloom c'est d'ici depuis
l'hôtel de matigon que nos premiers et
nos premières ministres ont Ré à bâtir
la
France chère Élisabeth pendant près de
20 mois c'est la France de demain que tu
as contribué à bâtir au côté du
président de la République tu as été une
première ministre d'action et de courage
ton histoire personnel tout autant que
ton éthique politique on fait de toi un
exemple
pour tes ministres pour les
parlementaires que tu as évoqué et plus
largement je le crois très profondément
pour les Français nous savons tous ce
que nous te devons ellisabeth madame la
Première ministre merci pour tout à
l'heure où je prends mes fonctions c'est
d'abord au président de la République
que j'adresse mes remerciements les plus
sincères cela a été dit ces dernières
heures j'ai pu le lire ou
l'entendre le le plus jeune président de
la République de l'histoire nomme le
plus jeune premier ministre de
l'histoire je ne veux y voir qu'un seul
symbole celui de l'audace et du
mouvement le symbole aussi est peut-être
surtout de la confiance celle accordée à
la jeunesse cette génération qui mérite
que l'on se batte pour elle sans relâche
ces derniers mois j'ai consacré toute
mon énergie à redonner espoir à chercher
à redonner espoir à cette génération à
ses parents en vrant pour l'école de la
République je le dis d'emblé mesdames et
messieurs j'emmène avec moi ici à
Matignon la cause de l'école je
réaffirme l'école comme étant la mère de
nos batailles celle qui doit être au
cœur de nos priorité et à qui je
donnerai comme premier ministre tous les
moyens d'action nécessaires pour sa
réussite elle sera l'une de mes
priorités absolu dans mon action à la
tête du gouvernement il y aura de ce
point de vue une forme
de continuité car en prenant des
décisions fortes sur la BAA en en
prenant des décisions fortes sur la
laïcité c'est pour la liberté que je me
suis engagé en prenant des décisions
fortes sur l'exigence et sur le choc des
savoirs c'est pour l'égalité que je me
suis engagé en prenant des décisions
fortes dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement c'est pour la fraternité que
je me suis engagé liberté égalité
fraternité cette devise de l'école est
aussi c
de la République et ce sera toujours ma
boussole mais mesdames et messieurs j'ai
conscience du contexte dans lequel je
prend mes fonctions trop de Français
doutent encore trop de Français doutent
de notre pays doutent d'eux même doutent
de notre avenir je pense au particulier
aux classes moyennes cœur battant de
notre pays artisan de la grandeur et de
la force de notre nation française ces
femmes ces hommes ces familles qui se
lèvent tous les matins pour aller
travailler qui peuplent notre territoire
et que l'on entend pas souvent mais qui
sont toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité cette classe moyenne qui
travaille et qui finance par son travail
nos services publics et notre modèle
social ces Français qui parfois ne s'y
retrouvent plus des Français doute mais
au fond je sais qu'ils espèrent aussi
car au fond de nous au plus profond de
nos consciences de français amoureux de
notre pays nous le savons la France ne
rimera jamais avec déclin car la France
elle rime avec sursaut elle rime avec
audace elle rime avec grandeur et c'est
précisément à cette tâche que je vais
m'ateler sous l'autorité du Président de
la République il a été réélu sur un
projet clair un projet d'action de
transformation un projet de reprise en
main de notre destin et de préparation
de celui de la prochaine
génération avec le président de la
République j'aurais donc un objectif
garder le contrôle de notre destin et
libérer notre potentiel français
garder le contrôle de notre destin c'est
lutter pour la maîtrise de notre modèle
social c'est agir pour la solidarité
entre les Français c'est assumer de
faire de l'autorité et du respect de
l'autre une valeur politique de premier
ordre et de et de la sécurité un
objectif absolument prioritaire c'est
agir pour le renforcement de nos
services publics au premier rang
desquels l'école j'en parlais il y a un
instant mais aussi la santé et en
premier lieu évidemment notre hôpital
c'est renforcé notre souveraineté
nationale et celle de l'Europe en
maîtrisant mieux notre immigration c'est
garantir l'avenir de notre planète qui
est le bien commun de notre humanité
libérer le potentiel français cela veut
dire continuer à transformer notre
économie autour de trois axes majeur
d'abord la priorité donnée au travail
travailler doit toujours être mieux
valorisé que ne pas travailler alors que
l'inflation je le sais continue de peser
sur la vie des Français ensuite c'est
l'acte 2 de la libération de notre
économie notamment avec la
simplification drastique de la vie de
nos entreprises et de nos entrepreneurs
et c'est enfin l'action résolue que nous
devons mener pour notre jeunesse dont le
talent ne demande qu'à s'exprimer dans
ce chantier avec le président de la
République nous ne partons pas de nulle
part depuis plus de 6 ans tant a été
fait tant a été engagé et déjà des
résultats sont perceptibles dans la vie
des Français nous avons un taux de
chômage historiquement bas depuis un
certain nombre d' ané tu y as largement
contribué en tant que ministre et
première ministre mais pour les années à
venir temps reste encore à faire c'est
la tâche à laquelle je consacrerai toute
mon énergie avec la même méthode qui est
la mienne celle que j'ai toujours
utilisé dans mes fonctions poser des
diagnostics clairs sans jamais mentir au
français et mettre en place des actions
fortes concrètes sans tabou dire la
vérité agir sans attendre voilà ce que
sera mon action à la tête du
gouvernement de la France mesdames et
messieurs avant de conclure je veux
avoir à nouveau une pensée pour le
président de la République lui redire
toute ma gratitude toute ma fidélité je
veux avoir un mot pour notre Parlement à
la majorité je dis ma reconnaissance et
ma promesse de toujours rester l'un des
leurs aux oppositions je leur dis que
nous avons en commun le destin de notre
nation que nous ne serons évidemment pas
d'accord sur tout que nous nous
opposerons mais aussi je leur fais la
promesse de toujours les écouter
toujours les respter parce qu'à travers
eux c'est la voix de millions de
Français qui s'expriment je veux avoir
un mot pour nos élus locaux qui sont eux
aussi les garants de notre République
pour nos partenaires sociaux oui ils
sont nos partenaires avec tout ce que
cela emporte d'exigence et de franchise
parce que chaque jour compte je réunirai
toutes ces forces vives du pays dès
cette semaines pour pour enclencher
ensemble cette nouvelle étape avant de
conclure je veux avoir une pensée pour
Édouard Philippe qui fut le premier à me
faire confiance en me nomant au
gouvernement il y a plus de 5 ans vous
pensa évidemment pour toi Élisabeth que
je remercie à nouveau pour ta confiance
et je pense évidemment à Jean Castex
avec qui j'ai tant appris ici à à
matigon en tant que secrétaire d'État
auprès de Lui porte-parole du
gouvernement j'ai appris ici avec lui à
ses côtés le fonctionnement de Matignon
l'exigence de la tâche de Premier
ministre et aussi l'importance de
l'amitié en politique je veux lui dire
que je sais ce que je lui doit ce que
notre famille politique lui doit et ce
que la France lui doit je veux pour
conclure m'adresser directement aux
Français à tous les Français où qu'ils
vivent dans l'Hexagone dans les outrmers
ou à l'extérieur de nos frontières quel
que soit leur parcours de vie quel que
soi leurs opinions politique peu importe
qui ils aiment ou ce en quoi ils croient
je veux leur dire qu'ils pourront
toujours compter sur sur moi leur dire
qu'avec le président de la République
chaque jour chaque minute chaque seconde
leur sera consacré parce qu'il n'y a
rien de plus beau rien de plus fort rien
de plus grand que de servir la France et
les Français je vous
remercie
j'ai travaillé sans relâche sans
chercher les coups d'éclat ce sont les
mots d'éliisabeth borne j'emmène avec
moi ici à Matignon la cause de l'école a
dit Gabriel Atal qui remonte les marches
de Matignon et qui laisse ellisabeth
born saluer le le personnel on savoure
et on écoute ce qui se passe dans la
cour de matinon parce que c'est toujours
un bon moment et puis on revient dans un
instant pour en discuter
Elisabeth borne fidèle à elle-même c'est
allé très vite
elle était assez froide non la
l'ancienne Première ministre il serait
vous n'avez pas trouvé oui elle était
sobre je dirais
oui ça explose un peu dans les oreilles
mais vous inquiétez pas tout plutôt
assez sobre elle a beaucoup parlé de ce
qu'elle a fait elle a pas
tellement je dirais de mots très
chaleureux pour son successeur c'est Mo
dire
a surtout insisté sur son œuvre auprès
son action auprès du président de la
République en qualité de ministre en
qualité de de premierre ministre elle a
montré que elle avait tenu la barre et
que
elle l'avait tenu firement dans des
temps compliqués elle a évoqué
évidemment la la la réforme de des
retraitesétait pas rien la loi sur
l'immigration et elle a eu mot aussi sur
les femmes euh ça vous aura pas échappé
elle est revenue sur ses propos qu'elle
avait eu pour les petites filles quand
elle est arrivé à Matignon et qui
étaient des propos qui étaient plutôt
d'ailleurs qui avaient été très
remarqués et
euh bah elle estime que effectivement
les femmes n'ont pas encore tout à fait
acquise acquis leur leur leur leur
espace l'espace suffisant dans le monde
politique en tous les cas puisquelle
elle a dit qu'elle allait continuer à se
battre là-dessus elle nous a aussi donné
comme information qu'elle siégerait
qu'elleit bien siégé au Palais Bourbon
qu'elle allait devenir l'une des leures
puisqu'elle a salué les députés élu
député oui elle a elle avait pris un une
forme de risque parce qu'elle non plus
n'avait jamais été élu avant d'être élu
dans le Calvados elle a parlé de
coconstruction de dialogue voilà sa
méthode et elle a salué les oppositions
constructives elle a défendu son bilan
TR elle en a trouvé effectivement mais
évidemment qu'elle a défendu son bilan
c'est normalou parfois on se souvient de
Jean Castex qui n'avait pas vraiment
était dans cette optique là il avait
surtout parlé d'Élisabeth borne il avait
profité de tous les gens qui étaient
dans la cour autour de lui cétait pas
tout à fait la même chose c'était pas du
tout la même chose il avait pas la même
gravité il y avait peut-être pas la même
bon on était on tournait une page aussi
hein le président de la République
venait d'être réélu c'était un peu
différent donc là effectivement c'est
très différent
et ce qu'on remarquera surtout c'est
effectivement les intentions et le
discours du premier ministre entrant oui
et on y vient Gabriel Atal al qui était
plus chaleureux avec elle euh et alors
il a remercié Emmanuel Macron deux fois
une fois au début une fois en fin de
discours et il a salué très
personnellement pas de manière
républicaine si je veux dire c'était
plus personnel non oui alors ce qui
était intéressant il y a il y a eu
beaucoup de choses de dites hein dans le
discours du du Premier ministre du futur
enfin du Premier ministre entrant la
première des choses c'est que on peut se
poser la question de savoir et on a
raison de le faire est-ce qu'il va
garder le portefeuille de l'éducation
c'est ce qui semblait indiqué mais il
peut aussi avoir dit qu'il allait
continuer à suivre le dossier de
l'éducation comme il va suivre tous les
dossiers en qualité de premier ministre
et puis qu' quand même un PR j'emmène
avec moi ici à Matignon la cause de
l'école oui mais il peut le la cause de
l'école c'est aussi la cause que le
Président de la République avait avait
nommé en arrivant pour son 2e mandat euh
il y a des chances pour qu'effectivement
il reste ministre de l'Éducation ça
c'est déjà fait comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure on se souvient de Ron bar
qui avait été Premier ministre et
ministre des Finances ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose l'ANT
c'est pas clairement établi he là il y a
toujours un petit suspense peut-être
encore plus avec ce qu'il vient de dire
voilà la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement sa
fidélité au président de la République
qui a répété d'une certaine façon il
aurait été quand même assez déplacé
qu'il ne le fasse pas alors qu'il lui
doit tout sans sans Emmanuel Macron il
serait pas il serait pas là et il aurait
pas fait la carrière ante qu'il a faite
jusqu'à présent sur le front ministériel
la troisième chose qui me paraît très
importante et qui vient confirmer ce
qu'on pensait c'est qu'il a s'est
adressé aux classes moyennes oui or les
classes moyennes c'est un peu celle qui
aujourd'hui ont tendance justement à
bouder la politique parce que elle
manque de résultat ou alors à se tourner
vers Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national justement parce que ils ont un
discours qui est clair et qui leur
convient qui leur conviennent et qui
leur convient pardon et donc c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est de montrer que
dans la perspective des élections
européennes et bien on disait qu'il
était un contrefeu à l'effet Bardella à
l'effet rassemblement national et que
évidemment il se pose effectivement en
concurrent direct de Monsieur Bardella
en concurrent direct pour la majorité
présidentielle de du rassemblement
national dans le cadre de cette élection
européenne c'est assez intéressant parce
que lors des dernières élections c'était
les législatives et Elisabeth born on le
dit souvent la première ministre porte
la majorité hein c'est ça avant une
élection il va avoir le même boulot sauf
que visiblement il s'y attèle
immédiatement là il a bien compris que
l'erreur d'éliisabeth born il devait
plus la reproduire c'est assez flagrant
et c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que il a conscience qu'il y a un
travail considérable à faire sur le plan
politique économique électoral pour pour
essayer de répondre aux attentes de ce
cette de ce de ces Français dit de la
classe moyenne alors c'est vaste la
classe moyenne mais on peut considérer
que c'est ces Français qui de plus en
plus se détournent de la politique parce
qu'ils sont déçus de leur personnel
politique et des
résultats qui sont enregistrés Gabriel
Atal qui lui aussi a fait son bilan hein
du peu de temps qu'il est resté à à
l'éducation nationale il a parlé de la
BAA a parlé du harcèlement scolaire il
en a il a voulu il y a une trème chose
il y a encore une chose qu'il faut noter
euh quand il a rendu hommage à tous les
premier ministres qu'il a servi il y en
a un qui a eu un hommage plus
particulièrement appuyé c'est Monsieur
Jean Castex quand il était ministre
pendant le covid d'ailleurs Premier
ministre pendant le covid et pourquoi il
a choisi Jean Castex parce que Jean
Castex vous trouvez qu'il l'a plus sal
il a commencé par éedouard Philippe qui
lu il a dit le premier à donner ma
chance non non non non non il a dit
premier évidemment il Filip parce que
c'était le premier après c'était madame
borne par dernière il a choisi la part
du roi je dirais c'était pour Jean
Castex et pourquoi Jean Castex parce que
Jean Castex correspond aussi précisément
et bien justement à ce type de
personnage qui peut plaire et qui a plu
d'une certaine façon à cette classe
moyenne qui est issue de la province
c'est Jean Castex c'est un peu si vous
voulez dans le profil c'est un peu
l'antiatal Atal c'est un produit de la
ville c'est un produit urbain c'est un
un homme qui vient plutôt de la gauche
alors que Jean vientite la droite donc
c'est et c'est c'est pas c'est pas du
tout un noin qui est rendu hommage un
hommage aussi appuyé à Jean Castex
complètement il a parlé du sursaut de la
France et il se déplacera très
rapidement puisqu'il part dans le Pas de
calis Gabriel Atal premier déplacement
c'était un un déplacement qui était
prévu par Madame borne oui depuis
dimanche soir on savait que elle doivait
aller dans le Pas de Calais qui
malheureusement vit les pieds dans l'eau
depuis maintenant pas mal de temps il y
a pas mal de de gens qui sont dans dans
vraiment dans une période très
compliquée en cette ce début d'année et
donc bah il va il va accomplir ce ce
voyage à la place de Madame born y je
vous libère mais je voulais connaître si
vous l'avez le calendrier on s'attend à
quoi là dans les jours qui viennent
alors vous avez peut-être pas les dates
mais l'ordre en tout cas on va en tous
les cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il va
alors il va il va y avoir la composition
du gouvernement cette composition du
gouvernement elle va intervenir josepér
ici à la fin de la semaine quand même et
puis après ben on va arriver ce weekend
on sera la mi-janvier et normalement
après la mi- janvier mais il était prévu
qu'il a une adresse enfin un rendez-vous
avec la nation président deé est pas là
le rendez-vous avec la nation non je
pense que le rendez-vous avec la nation
ça sera peut-être autre chose quand même
et puis il y a le discours de politique
générale ou du Premier ministre suivi ou
non d'un vote à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce qu'on va voir Emmanuel Macron
dans les médias dans les jours qui
viennent vous me parlez de ce
rendez-vous avec la nation ou est-ce
qu'il va la prendre l'esace à minist il
y aura rien avant la composition du
gouvernement je pense pas non ouais nous
verrons dans les semaines à venir quel
est le comportement d'Emmanuel Macron
avec G un discours de politique générale
du du Premier
ministre Édouard Philippe oui qui qui
était intervenu après un grand discours
du président de la République au congrès
à versaill on s'en souvient c'était très
différent Emmanuel Macron
venit élu merci beaucoup y trard on est
assez impatient non mais faut le dire on
aime ou on aime pas Gabriel Atal on est
d'accord ou pas avec ces idées on a
envie de voir ce que ça donne merci
beaucoup merci à vous de nous suivre
vous êtes sur le Figaro.fr on continue à
voir ce live texte vous avez toutes les
dernières informations les dernières
réactions de l'opposition qui vous vous
en doutez n'est pas très contente et qui
n'est pas emballé par l'arrivée de
Gabriel àal bon
après-midi